at least 34 people have been killed in a
landslide in Northwestern Columbia
unusually heavy rains this year have led
the government to declare a national
disaster they've been several deadly
landslides caused by rains linked to the
weather phenomenon La Nina
in the latest tragedy a wall of Earth
crashed down on a bus in the Andes
region
dance of mud and debris
Rescuers did find some survivors
in the Grimace of circumstances
we were able to rescue alive a
seven-year-old girl who is currently in
hospital
unfortunately we found her clinging to
her mother
there was also a little boy a little
more than a year old her brother
they died in the tragic situation we are
facing
the landslide hit a highway in
Northwestern Columbia catching drivers
by surprise
I didn't feel anything but when I did
the car was already being run over by
the landslide
my car is totally destroyed
scientists say climate change is making
the weather patterns more erratic the
government says heavy rains in Colombia
are the worst they have been in 40 years
so far this year events caused by the
bad weather have killed more than 200
people
CW correspondent Nicole Reese is in the
Colombian capital Bogota and she
explained how much worse than usual the
rain is
we were looking at hundreds of thousands
of people who have been affected by
these Reigns this year in different
regions of Colombia and more than 200
people have died in connection to these
rainfalls so I think this together with
the pictures that we just saw gives you
a pretty good idea of just how severe
the situation across the country in the
different communities is and it's
especially communities in the rural
areas with dirt roads and poor
infrastructure that are more vulnerable
and more effective if we are affected as
we've just seen in this Village and this
is all due to a phenomenon called La
Nina which is pretty strong this year it
comes every few years and it basically
means that there are stronger winds
across the Pacific here in South America
and they lower the water surface
temperature below the normal and this
causes an imbalance in the pressure in
the air which causes then these heavy
rainfalls some experts also believe that
there are links to climate change and
the Heat team global climate that make
La Nina stronger than the usual